remember that our program is mostly
supported by
individual memberships which you can
find at joinpakman.com and for the next
six days only you can use the coupon
code 2020 now
to get 66 off of the
membership of your choice at
joinpackman.com
i want to be really clear as i talk
about this next story
the most important part of this election
is removing donald trump and replacing
him with joe biden
so that we can start to get the country
back on the right path the country has
been taken over by lunatic extremists
and ignorant clowns in washington dc
corrupt fools and delusional narcissists
this is not about even republicans and
democrats
i'll be having a conversation today with
the conservative douglas murray
about actual conservatism this is
something very different this has been a
coup
of incompetence which must be remedied
it's dangerous
it's creepy it's disgusting it has to be
fixed for the sake of all of our futures
but in addition to that watching donald
trump
increasingly triggered by former
president barack obama's speeches
has really been a delight last week
barack obama rallied for joe biden in
philadelphia pennsylvania
over the weekend barack obama rallied
for joe biden in miami florida
and every time trump starts tweeting
conspiracies about barack obama
attacks on barack obama because he's
just so jealous
of barack obama and yesterday barack
obama was in orlando florida for joe
biden and again
just hammering trump in exactly the way
that most gets to trump and trump's
insecurities
i really think obama is going to make
trump explode
by election day at this rate check this
out here is barack obama going right
after
trump on something trump is very
insecure about which is the size of
trump's
crowds which is of course so meaningless
but it just goes to the heart of donald
trump's narcissism
any interest in doing the work or
helping anybody
but himself and his friends or treating
the presidency as anything more than a
reality show
that can give him the attention that he
craves and he does crave attention
this week with everything that's
happening you know what he brought up
he was fussing about the crowd size at
the inauguration again
saying his was bigger
who who who is thinking about that right
now
nobody except him another theme is that
trump
either tries to undo what barack obama
did
or tries to take credit for it it's one
or the other either undo it or claim
that you actually did it
and again barack obama going right to
the heart of that by talking about
jobs numbers which did slow down when
donald trump became president of the
united states
that complicated donald trump
likes to claim he built this economy but
i just want to remind you that
america created 1.5 million more jobs
in the last three years of the obama
biden administration
than in the first three years of the
trump pence
administration that's a fact look it up
it is a fact and i do encourage you to
look it up and of course
any reasonable person understands that
there is much more
complexity than merely obama was better
at job creation than trump but it is
true
those are the numbers and donald trump
can't handle that and he hates that and
he lies about it
and then this is just great barack obama
addressing donald trump's claim
that he's been the best president for
black people
since abraham lincoln even better than
the actual black president take a look
at this
and he wants to take credit for it says
he's the best president for black folks
since abe lincoln
man now his advisors are out there
saying
including his son-in-law his son-in-law
says black folks have to want to be
successful
that's the problem
who are these folks what history books
do they read who do they talk to
don't read is that what is going on and
[Laughter]
what wild times we live in huh and then
lastly here barack obama going after
donald trump
for being enamored uh with global
dictators
and authoritarians saying of course they
want trump to win
and over donald trump being so triggered
by leslie stahl
from his 60 minutes interview our
current president he whines that 60
minutes is too tough
you think he's going to stand up to
dictators he thinks leslie stalls a
bully
just yesterday just yesterday
he said that putin of russia
she of china and kim jong-un of north
korea
want him to win we know
we know because you've been giving them
whatever you want
for the last four years of course they
want you to win
that's not a good thing we'll talk a
little bit more about leslie stahl
momentarily but
really just finely tuned to get to
donald trump
and to throw trump off balance and of
course
these are not highly substantive policy
rallies that barack obama is doing
although they have more substance than
trump's
but they don't have to be this is barack
obama this isn't the candidate this is a
surrogate
in this case a surrogate for joe biden
who's going out
as a popular person within the party to
fire up the base and really hitting the
right notes to trigger donald trump
and boy has it worked now am i childish
for thoroughly enjoying when barack
obama does this
am i uh is it infantile for me to relish
obama taking the gloves off and taking
these shots at trump
because it angers trump more than
anything i care about policy and we've
taken
uh biden's policy on taxes and done a
deep dive as economic policy energy
policy
climate policy the whole thing and that
really matters
but isn't this great in some way and
importantly
a really important message on voting
from barack obama yesterday and this is
why i think it's great for him to be
doing these rallies at all
barack obama said we can't be complacent
we were complacent last time and look
what happened
and by the way i think he should also be
saying those people on the
i know he won't say it i say it the
people on the left who said
hillary trump it's all the same they're
both neoliberal shills or
tools of the establishment look at the
supreme court my friends look at the
supreme court
uh and the real key here is as barack
obama says
no complacency six days to go the latest
numbers
on early and mail-in voting as of this
morning
71 million early votes have been cast
that's more than half of the total
number of votes
in 2016. of the 71 million
48 million roughly have been mailing the
rest have been in person
now of those 48
of early votes are democrats 29
are republicans you might see that and
say beautiful joe biden's got this
remember of those polled
who have not yet voted overwhelmingly
they support trump
so we have to understand a lot of the
early vote
seems to be going for biden those
waiting to vote on election day
seem to be leaning trump it is not going
to be the blowout that these early
numbers suggest
we all must vote texas is really voting
87
of the total 2016 turnout has already
been cast
in texas very much suggesting
blow it out of the water record turn out
in texas and i look forward to seeing
those numbers